find the most innocent uncontroversial
video on YouTube scroll down ever so
slightly and you'll suddenly hear a
thousand furious Internet voices yelling
this video about puppies has sparked a
heated investigation of 911
YouTube isn't alone toxic comment
sections are everywhere but some sites
are better than others
reddit comm is full of thoughtful
productive conversations so why does
this box create such anger and this one
stimulates so much thought the
explanation seems simple YouTube has a
very wide audience attracting enough
trolls to ruin conversation for everyone
reddit is much more isolated each
community united by a common interest
this theory isn't wrong but it's
incomplete comments are surely affected
by who writes them but how a comment
system is designed also greatly affects
what is written if you're not quite sold
consider this by default predators are
subscribed to a group of communities
which because of this are filled with
large diverse audiences like YouTube if
audiences were the only factor default
subreddits would be as terrible as
YouTube they are worse than the rest of
Reddit but not nearly as bad as YouTube
that difference between default
subreddits and YouTube can be attributed
to differences on how the two systems
work
[Music]
comment boxes may look identical but
underneath our very different systems
which produce very different results
YouTube isn't only anonymous its
identity lists each comment stands on
its own
attached to nothing bringing out the
worst in every commenter redditors have
an identity a profile score and list of
comments you are anonymous enough to be
honest but invested enough to be
generally polite good reddit comments
are uploaded which increases your score
called karma like trophies karma is
completely useless but our brains are
motivated just the same this system is
far from perfect but it does encourage
people to make good posts given that no
one reads every comment the order in
which they appear is important the
YouTube algorithm is super secret but a
glance at an old video shows that recent
comments are shown first even above much
higher quality ones good comments
disappear into the void which also
disincentivizes writing them in the
first place reddit shows higher-quality
comments first which does just the
opposite democratic information comes at
a cost
people often upvote what they want or
assume to be true not what is it's not
uncommon for posts on the front page of
Reddit to be completely wrong the top
comment may totally debunk the post but
enough people up vote without ever
checking the comments that it doesn't
really matter if this doesn't sound
familiar you're probably one of those
people YouTube makes this especially bad
by burying replies and making
conversations so hard to follow that
most of us only read parent comments
[Music]
YouTube channels don't make money from
comments so any time spent moderating
them is time wasted and because there
are so many of them comments are usually
either barely policed at all or
completely disabled there is a report
button but it's either completely
useless or enough users think it is to
have the same effect reddit is full of
rules BOTS moderators and more rules
prohibited comments are quickly removed
and users quickly learn not to waste
time posting them think of all these
factors as filters through which
comments flow people have the same
thoughts on both websites but different
filters ultimately decide what comments
people post it's obvious that YouTube is
flawed but it isn't clear why they don't
lack the resources to improve and it's
not as if they aren't aware big
youtubers have complained quite vocally
for ages but it's only gotten worse over
time Twitter and Facebook are
problematic to spreading false news and
encouraging argument by forcing the most
complex issues into a mere 140
characters but it all makes sense when
you put yourself in their shoes if your
YouTube or Twitter or Facebook your only
goal is keeping people on the site
everything else is secondary more time
spent on YouTube is more ads watched and
more revenue earned spreading accurate
information would be nice but it's just
a bonus YouTube doesn't improve because
there's no reason to they have all the
numbers we don't and they've found what
keeps people's interest when you have a
monopoly you maximize profits and let
people be as outraged as they'd like
Facebook has no commitment to the truth
if fake news stories are what keep your
attention so be it in their minds
they're just providing what you demand
how kind
reddit also wants to sell ads but their
algorithm is why users come at all their
goals happen to be aligned with what we
want
it's easy to see YouTube and Facebook
and Twitter as the bad guys but they
themselves are also products of a much
larger system and behind every bad
situation is a lousy system politicians
are made corrupt by the system that
created them and the problem will
clickbait stems from the constant
struggle of journalists to put food on
the table this isn't to say that
everyone is innocent but to explain why
things are the way they are the design
of a system is like a stamp announcing
exactly what it will produce we should
be outraged by the stamp itself not at
what it produces this video should teach
you that a system that relies on people
being good is a bad system we can spend
an eternity fixing everything that comes
out of the machine we've built or we can
fix the machine when it comes to YouTube
we can't change how the comment sections
work but we can control the larger
system of which YouTube is a product of
remember companies only care about one
thing which also means they aren't
attached to the way things are YouTube
has zero loyalty to their design if it
stops being profitable if you really
care about making change you need only
move your resources and companies will
follow
[Music]